restaurant boulangerie commerce ou
encore pharmacie dans ce petit village
de 700 hommes tout est présent ou
presque voilà maintenant 7 ans que cette
commune de Gironde est à la recherche de
médecin généraliste afin de remplacer ce
parti à la retraite
le maire de la ville la même acheter un
local refait à neuf pour qu'il puisse
établir sur place
voilà donc passé un des locaux qui est
prévu pour être aménagé pour un nouveau
médecin leur vidament mais pour
l'instant il est un peu vide puisque les
le mobilier et
dire les équipements le détail des
équipements et avoir avec chaque médecin
évidemment avec deux chacun
malgré tous les efforts consentis les
recherches reste zen la majorité des
jeunes médecins pour le choix de la
ville au détriment de la campagne
les médecins l'étang rare et bien
certains l'ont quand même en des actions
sur certaines sont les gens sont
parfaitement compréhensible par exemple
concernant leur leur temps de travail
parce que
c'est parfaitement compréhensible
mais il est cherche aussi
la possibilité d'avoir des spectacles
des
équipements sportifs exetera qui
n'existe pas toujours ou du moins pas à
qui sont pas à proximité immédiate dans
dans les villages et même dans les
villes moyennes dégâts face à cette
pénurie de médecins français une des
solutions et de faire appel à des
médecins étrangers avec le même manque
de réussite au début de l'année 2021 on
a eu une proposition d'un médecin
rwandais qui était prêt à venir
s'installer dans notre cabinet médical
le seul problème c'est qu'il n'avait pas
travaillé pendant 2 ans en milieu
hospitalier français qui n'avait pas de
référence donc impossible pour lui de
prendre le son poste de médecin libéral
avoir y a Sandra qui sont dans le
village le premier réflexe des habitants
et de se rendre en pharmacie une
pharmacie qui a dû mettre en place une
cabine de téléconsultation
malheureusement cela n'est pas suffisant
pour pouvoir gérer tous les patients il
faut donc faire plusieurs kilomètres
pour trouver un médecin qui peut
accepter nouvelle clientèle une solution
alternative difficile voire impossible
pour certaines personnes en a beaucoup
de patients qui ont énormément de mal à
trouver même en se déplaçant à 10 15 20
km les médecins sont surchargés donc ils
ne veulent pas deux il faut attendre
très longtemps avant d'avoir un médecin
traitant donc et Éric pour nous et pour
nos patients surtout pour la continuité
des soins c'est assez important de
pouvoir trouver quelqu'un pour être sur
la commune et pour cela le gouvernement
a prévu un plan d'accès aux soins nommé
ma santé 2022 en développant les stages
de médecine générale ou en versant
déprime aux étudiants l'objectif inciter
les jeunes praticien à s'installer dans
les déserts médicaux et permettra des
communes comme Gauriac de trouver son
nouveau généraliste